well so I think most of the greatest
innovations that ever happened in any
society in the world happened from
actually the roots from the people and
waiting for government to do anything in
terms of changing things if you wait for
the government's nothing will happen you
have to actually initiate and go ahead
and do the change and do something you
believe in and if you actually believe
in something go for it if government
wants to join you later on you want but
if not you have many other people in the
world foundations in the world people
care want to join your efforts and want
to do the change they'll join you and
don't worry about governments
governments have other issues they're
dealing with and if they feel you did
such a great thing and they want to be
partners with you they negotiate with
him how to be partners with you but we
did in Israel is get volunteers who are
you know thousands of volunteers from
all sectors Jews and Arabs and Israelis
and Palestinians wherever Weber cure is
about saving lives we don't go into
politics we only care about saving lives
we are paramedics EMTs and doctors
nurses who work out regular life and we
have jobs everyone has own job and if
something happens in our perimeter we
could actually get the emergency alert
from one head dispatching center in
Israel and alert us about anyone anyone
that's in stress and within two min two
minutes the three minutes I would be
there and save his life so this started
actually from a group of volunteers that
we started a few years ago we said why
do we have to wait till an ambulance
arrives to take some his life if we
could do it ourselves we're paramedics
and the guy that's choking is in the
next building why wait till he dies or
he's brain-damaged we could do the
change and that's how we saved so many
thousands and thousands of people this
year we treated 181,000 people in the
country and many of them come from
sectors or people I don't even know and
that never
I knew them but I got closer to these
sectors and I got connected to other
people what would never know because I
save their life and that's how we did it
will change and that's how other people
joined us and then we have close to
2,000 volunteers in Israel who are
joining us and they are doing this
volunteer work with no pay 24 hours a
day seven days a week and anytime anyone
needs them for anything if it's an
emergency for sure if it's a heart
attack while car accident or a anything
a stroke these guys would leave
everything would leave their jobs will
leave home and run and save other
people's eyes and we don't look what
color that other person has is he know
me does he know me all right or if he's
my religion or not my religion we are
doing the good work that everyone should
do in the world saving other people's
lives caring about others and I think
good things will happen from that the
real change will happen from the roots
not from the government's